another day at the office Antarctica
right now we're on a glacier with lots
of crevasse so you can see behind me
basically if we fell in a crevasse you
would be my anchor so I just have to
fill my bag here with some snow because
one of the challenges at working is that
almost always blowing and if I let this
bag go even in a light wind like right
now it'll be gone fairly stiff snow and
snow is extremely strong
that's why unintended curved asphalt
here very uncommon that said when they
happen the consequences can be very bad
so they just have to take precautions
so this is one end of this dipole
positive negative and it's measuring
electric field because the surface here
is not very conductive and so you need
to give it a bit of a boost at the end
so these are preamps that one of the
other scientists John invented when he
built specifically for this work and
there's no there's nothing else the
world of these views for last week went
out feeling bad and came home feeling
worse yeah you just kind of keep going
everyone has to work pretty hard these
connections are not very strong and then
we lent the helicopter the rotor puts a
lot of air glass and the worst thing
would be to set it up really nice and
beautifully and have it work when we sit
in there and then have the helicopter
blow the connections apart so this
connection is pretty strong but for this
one I just leave a little bit of extra
give it a little wrap this like that
can't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]